I cannot believe that the culture would
do this to me right before my wedding
it's right before my wedding and the
culture is trying to kill me with all
this winning not only if you saw it made
me sick and tired last week I was
congested I was tired I was sick now it
might kill me all of the winning as
little Rocketman runs his mouth the
United States sends a clear message and
backs it up with action what a welcome
change meanwhile Donald Trump triggers
the left into attacking the American
flag again I don't know why they keep
doing this but great bring it on
we will analyze the virtues of common
sense then Patrick coffin joins the show
to give me in the world advice on
marriage we could we could all use that
you know there's a lot of confusion
these days finally the mailbag
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot to get to today a lot of these
mm-hmm ooh those tears are good before
we get into what's going on on the
culture and the politics and get to our
guests and answer all your questions
let's talk about the upside let's talk
about upside a wonderful sponsor for the
show they help keep the lights on and
they will help you travel uh you know
being an astronaut was a pretty cool job
flying through space walking on the moon
he had a nice parade that's all very
good but don't forget astronauts would
have not have been able to do any of
that without the great folks at Mission
Control could you imagine having a team
like that supporting you on your
business trip well that's what you get
when you book your next business trip at
upside comm I'm flying out tomorrow
morning and you know when I when I
travel in the old days before up side
travel for business I'd have to move a
flight you know or I'd have to do this
and that's just me calling sweet little
ELISA and saying like you got to call
them just I don't know Mac I get I'm too
busy I'm doing nothing stuff right
Merritt don't you don't need that use up
site it'll save you time it'll save you
money up side will be your Mission
Control look out for you every step of
the way handle any problem that might
pop up they've got a team of specialists
working 24/7 to make sure your flight
hotel car rental all go off without a
hitch
they monitor your trip around the clock
proactively keeping you posted on
everything from you know is it gonna
rain or their alternate flights if you
want to squeeze in one more meeting
which you know that means if you want to
stick around the bar a little longer
have you ever experienced that level of
service before our business trip no way
once you have experienced a committed
team looking after every detail of your
trip you can never go back
time is money hassle frustration get rid
of all that let upside do it for you for
easy booking competitive prices and a
team that always has your back book your
next business trip at upside calm for a
limited time it's my wedding and I'm
giving you a present for a limited time
when you book your first business trip
with up side you will get a minimum $100
dot-com Amazon gift card $100 calm
Amazon gift is that how that goes $100
amazon.com gift card just go to up side
calm slash cough facl VF e fe get a
letter Kofi Fane your business trip up
side comm slash cough FA Co V Fe Fe get
at least a $100 amazon.com gift
card that's pretty good 600 our minimum
purchase required while supplies last
seaside for complete details there's
always a little thing at the end but
it's a really good deal and really great
service so Donald Trump is spiking the
football mmm you see that pun you like
that Donald Trump is spiking the
football because the NFL announced
yesterday that they would no longer
allow these players to kneel down and
that this had always been the rule but
now they weren't enforcing it for the
last two years and so they will not
allow players to protest the American
flag on the field at the NFL here is
Donald Trump's reaction the NFL has but
the owners have voted unanimously to
approve a new national anthem rule that
says if you're not going to stay and
stay in the locker room if you go to the
field you have to stand if you have a
protest your team's gonna get fined this
is the first time you're hearing this
what's your reaction mr. president I
think that's good I don't think people
should be staying in locker rooms but
still I think it's good you have to
stand proudly for the national anthem
well you shouldn't be playing you
shouldn't be there maybe you shouldn't
be in the country you have to stand
proudly for the national anthem and the
NFL owners did the right thing if that's
what they've done if that is the story
do you feel like you push this story
forward and you push this to a
conclusion I think the people pushed it
forward this was not me I brought it out
I think the people pushed it forward
this country is very smart we're very
smart people and you know that's
something ideally could have been taken
care of when it first started it would
have been a lot easier but if they did
that they're doing the right thing
absolutely right absolutely right
everything he just said is absolutely
right they shouldn't be in the country
if they hate it so much if they hate the
country so much they should not be here
the country gives them a lot of
privileges a lot of opportunities it
defends their liberties it defends their
life it's a lovely place everybody's
trying to come here and if you hate it
if you want to disrespect it and you
complain about it and whine about it all
the time
leave leave go away we don't want you
here if you if you hate the country go
somewhere else that's fine oh there are
other places it's kind of harder to
sneak into those other places because
every other country enforces its own
immigration laws unlike the United
States but get out of here he's
absolutely right
also I'd like to point out here people
say Trump is an
persist this is one of the memes Donald
tree is a big narcissist he only wants
us to bet himself and this and that I
don't see that here what Donald what
Barack Obama would have said if it were
some some issue that he had participated
in you'd say well listen I want a
million bucks and Michelle's I'll all
the future leaders of America are gonna
be a million Barack's in Michelle's he
just sees everybody in in the light of
himself he just looking in a mirror all
day long but Brian kill me to ask strong
Trump says mr. president do you take
credit for this he says you know yeah I
don't think so I think it's the people
and he's and Trump is right about that
by the way this is not about Donald
Trump the New York Times is so angry
they they ran a big headline today about
how that the NFL kneels to Donald Trump
the NFL didn't kneel to Donald Trump the
NFL kneeled to the American people who
stopped watching their programming the
NFL realized if it wanted to stay on TV
and have people keep buying their
products they would have to stop
spitting in the face of people's country
which they loved this hadn't this
actually didn't have a lot to do with
Donald Trump what Donald Trump largely
is we talked about yesterday on the show
how Donald Trump is a people person he's
living in reality and he sees the
present pretty well so it looks like
he's seeing the future
cuz everyone else is living in the past
and what he does is he sees what people
are saying and then Donald Trump is this
big gigantic microphone he is just a
huge microphone for what's going on in
the culture and that's why it resonates
that's why we he says it people say oh
he's saying what we're all thinking
that's why he gets 50,000 people to go
to his rallies that's what he goes there
and he's he's tapping into the zeitgeist
he's tapping in to what's going on in
the culture and amplifying it but it
didn't originate with him and so look
that's good I'm glad that the NFL wants
to keep its money and stop you know
giving the one-finger salute to its
audience but now we have some skittish
conservatives who are up in arms about
this so the left is crying about free
speech the left only cares about free
speech by the way when it suits their
purposes so they don't care about free
speech at universities they don't care
about free speech and for defended by
the government all they care about is
free speech for millionaire athletes
during one particular sort of athletic
broadcast that's the only time they care
about
but now some conservatives are up in
arms about this David French whom I like
personally but he's lost it with this
op-ed he wrote an op-ed in the New York
Times the op-ed is called conservatives
fail the NFL's free speech test and this
this line of thinking is so wrong and
detrimental to the conservative cause
and to the defense of free speech and
really I'm mostly just peeved at David
right now because he published it in the
New York Times what are you doing you're
right for a great publication called the
National Review you right there don't
don't put it in the New York Times for
goodness sakes so here's what he wrote
here's that here is his argument and
I'll explain why it's wrong French says
quote the United States is in the grips
of a free speech paradox at the same
time that the law provides more
protection to personal expression than
any time in the nation's history large
numbers of Americans feel less free to
speak the culprit isn't government
censorship but instead corporate
community and peer intimidation and then
he goes on a little bit and he says that
you know conservatives are saying that
it's different when it's about the flag
of French rights quote but this is
different they say this isn't about
politics it's about the flag I agree it
is different because it's about the flag
the censorship is even worse where to
begin where to begin with this this so
what David is saying is that
conservatives talk a good game on free
speech but also we don't want our
national athletes to spit on their
country and he says that this is a
contradiction this is of course it's not
we're criticizing the content of the
speech but we're also criticizing this
particular speech and attack on the flag
because it is nonsensical because you're
using the rights defended enshrined in
our Constitution protected by our or
communities and our governments and our
law enforcement that you're using those
rights to attack those rights to attack
the source of those rights which is the
country the star-spangled banner the
flag which is a symbol of the country it
doesn't make any sense
G K Chesterton talked about this he said
there is a thought that stops thought
and that's the only thought that ought
to be stopped so as a matter of free
speech the the players they can protest
the flag all they want they just can't
do it
during the broadcast they can't do it on
the NFL's dime and they can't do it
because the NFL will disappear people
will just stop watching do the NFL
owners have any free speech do they have
any rights to air what they want to air
during their broadcast do they have any
can they tell the employee hey you can't
use our product to showboat you're
anti-american trash this this is what it
would be like I wonder if David will
write another column in The New York
Times about this one
if actors in Hollywood movies they're
filming the movie you know Stella Stella
I hate Donald Trump get him out of
office Stella's a cut what was that is
if what if a Hollywood actor inserted
his own political views in a Hollywood
movie and said you have to put that in
the final movie or you're abridging my
free speech you're censoring me if you
say no we're not where this movie studio
we're making a product they're writers
their directors there's the studio the
distributors we have a product and we
don't want you to we're hiring you to do
a job we're hiring you to say the lines
on the page we're not hiring you to run
your mouth about anti-american nonsense
and they say well that's my free speech
it's the same thing with the NFL these
guys these millionaire earthlies who get
paid to run around on grass and throw a
ball back and forth and enjoy the
wonderful prosperity that this country
has to offer
that we take a time off you know once a
week and just watch grown men run around
and play a game together they are hired
to do a job which is to run around and
throw that ball they are not hired to
voice their political views they can go
to Twitter later and say I hate America
they and I'm that's what they're saying
by the way when you protest the American
flag you're saying I hate America but I
protest America so they can let's find
take it to Twitter do whatever you want
but you can't do it on our dime there's
nothing contradictory about that and by
the way there's nothing contradictory
about disagreeing with the content of
the speech particularly when the content
of the speech undercuts free speech
itself there is a thought that stops
thought that's the only thought that
ought to be stopped and I wish
conservatives would would stop I don't
know if they're being obtuse or
pretending or they honestly don't see
that distinction but there is a thought
that stops thought that's categorically
different and by the way
that the NFL has a right to make its TV
shows and which is what it that's what a
football game is this a TV broadcast
paid for by advertisers under the NFL
and Hollywood movie makers have the
right to make their movies and employees
don't have the right to take over hold
that entire production hostage and air
their anti-american dribble that has
nothing to do with free speech at all
and it's a ridiculous argument before we
get to Patrick I've got a really good
guest he's gonna give me advice on
marriage I could use it before we get to
him I do want to talk about Trump
canceling the Korea summit the summit
with King John Kim jong-un so you know
we've seen they've been building this up
for a long time saying oh maybe you know
Trump I'll get the Nobel Peace Prize
they're all saying Trump really wants
that Nobel Peace Prize oh but will Kim
do it they cast a little coin and one of
the White House gift shops or something
okay now it's over now it's over here is
the letter that Donald Trump sent to Kim
jong-un I will explain why why this
really should give us a lot of
confidence in the guy and in Pompeo and
in John Bolton and the foreign policy
advisers around him because this move
was perfectly done
here's the letter quote dear mr.
chairman we greatly appreciate your time
patience and effort with respect to our
recent negotiations and discussions
relative to a summit long sought by both
parties which was scheduled to take
place on June 12th in Singapore we were
informed that the meeting was requested
by North Korea but that to us is totally
irrelevant it's dig you know you you
asked for it guys but hey who we don't
need to talk about that letter goes on I
was very much looking forward to being
there with you sadly based on the
tremendous anger and open hostility
displayed in your most recent statement
I feel it is inappropriate at this time
to have this long planned meeting
therefore please let this letter serve
to represent that the Singapore summit
for the good of both parties but to the
detriment of the world will not take
place you talk about your nuclear
capabilities but ours are so massive and
powerful that I pray to God they will
never have to be used it goes on I felt
a wonderful dialogue was building up
between you and me and ultimately it is
only that dialogue that matters
someday I look very much forward to
meeting you in the meantime I want to
thank you for the release of the
hostages who are now home with their
families that was a beautiful gesture
and very much appreciated if you change
your mind having to do with this most
important summit please do not hesitate
to call me or write the world in North
Korea in particular has lost a great
opportunity for lasting peace and great
prosperity and wealth this missed
opportunity is a truly sad moment in
history Sincerely Yours Donald J Trump
President of the United States of
America masterful absolutely masterful
the whoever wrote the letter I'm I don't
know you know presidents tend not to
write these things themselves and it's a
no sleight to President Gough FA but
whoever wrote it whether it was Stephen
Miller or Samba somebody Pompeyo or
something really superb because it has
that trump enos it does have all of that
you know he gets in there because Kim
jong-un is raising a ruckus now and
basically what he tried to do is move
the goal posts Kim jong-un Kim jong-un
where you know they're in dialog about
this meeting and Kim jong-un thought he
could turn up the heat on Donald Trump
on the Frog on America frog turn up the
heat so we were gonna get a bad deal out
of it and Trump said no he had the
willingness to step back this is a total
contrast to Barack Obama total contrast
Barack Obama with the Iran deal was so
desperate for that deal to happen he so
wanted his second nuclear peace bro
nuclear Nobel Peace Prize he wanted to
earn one of them he was so desperate he
would take any deal even if the deal
didn't give us anything
he was Iran kept changing the terms of
the deal they said hey let all of our
money free up in the banks okay hey fly
over a plane of cash and drop it off
okay yes sir whatever you want Iran
captures American sailors holds them
hostage takes humiliating pictures of
them broadcast them to the world what
does Obama do what did John Kerry do
this oh okay I'm sorry I'm okay thank
you thank you for not releasing more
video of our sailors being humiliated I
mean absolutely pathetic because they
couldn't accept a deal falling apart
Donald Trump's not like that the way you
negotiate the only way a negotiation
works is if you're actually willing to
walk away if you're not willing to walk
away that isn't a negotiation so what do
we get now out of all this the meetings
off the
is loving this right they say Trump's
not gonna get that Nobel Peace Prize
turns out Trump didn't give a darn about
that Nobel Peace Prize did he he didn't
he didn't care at all he just wants the
thing to happen someone asked him about
the Peace Prize he said yeah that'd be
fine a lot of people say I deserve one
but I just want the thing to happen I
want to accomplish the reality not just
the appearance of the thing which the
left loves I want the essence of the
thing which is a lasting peace and
denuclearization of Korea but just look
at what we've gotten out of this so we
got this crazy you know back and forth
media circus over this meeting now it's
over okay let's say it's actually over I
guess it could still turn on if it's
actually over we got three American
hostages released one of whom who's been
held for three years by North Korea and
North Korea demolished one of its
nuclear test sites today in punggye-ri I
think is vaguely how you pronounce it
but they actually demolished one of
their nuclear testing sites there was a
series of huge explosions foreign
journalists looked on we can actually
see it this actually happened so we got
two pretty big concessions out of it and
Donald Trump walked away because the
worst thing that could happen would have
been that the Obama policy the Obama did
this in Cuba too he went down and he
said hey Castro's I know that we've been
fighting you for years you almost
destroyed us with nuclear weapons 50
years ago you brutalize your own people
you're just monster thug mafia pinko
monsters but we'll give you whatever you
want so that we have the appearance of a
deal
so we have the appearance of peace so we
gave the Castros everything we got
nothing in return and now that's an
Obama deal Trump said no the worst thing
that could have happened is if we
legitimized Kim we allowed them to
maintain their weapons we we could have
ended up worse off than we were before
now because Trump was willing to walk
away we ended up way better off we get
those we you know we get those hostages
back and we get a nuclear site
demolished and maybe there'll be an
opportunity in the future and in Trump's
still he doesn't back down at all they
says you know you threatened your
nuclear weapons just remember we could
blow you off the map in a second in a
New York
minute we could have blow you off of the
face of the earth that's important
language that you know there's he has no
fear of looking like a failure he's just
doing the thing it's really beautiful
okay we got to get to Patrick we're
running a little late okay Patrick
coffin for nearly eight years hosted the
top-rated Catholic radio show in the
country Catholic Answers live and the
podcast Catholic Answers focus he's the
author of the contraception deception
Catholic teaching on birth control as
well as sex
au naturale what it is and why it's good
for your marriage and currently he's the
host of the Patrick coffin show Patrick
does a lot of things he's very very busy
Patrick thank you for being here thanks
for having me you know I would be here I
really wanted to turn the Catholicism up
to 11 as I prepare to Wed I'm getting on
a flight tomorrow to New York to begin
my bachelor party so I guess that could
that could end up being my last show
ever I suppose you know depending on how
the bachelor party goes up to 11 don't
look at it don't don't touch it yeah
don't even look at it yeah 11 it goes to
11
middle tip so is sir my first question
you are married
should I run away now should I leave a
michael shaped hole in the wall
somewhere you know do you have any
advice for me and the rest of the world
on marriage I'm so glad you put it that
way
don't do no Michael my my favorite quote
on marriage comes from Our Mutual
literary mentor GK Chesterton who said
marriage is a duel to the death that no
man of honor should decline that are
simpler words so yeah you my friend are
about to embark on the highest adventure
imaginable and that is the union of two
sinners each of which represent a mirror
I mean your your fiancee soon to be your
wife God willing will be your
introduction to you the real you it's
just a good two giant you know two-sided
mirrors and likewise to her you're
you're in for I call I call them the
three rings you there's a lot of talk of
the engagement ring and the wedding ring
well there's the suffer ring too
marriage can be hard you know marriage
is it's the ultimate form of friendship
between two sexually attracted people
and when people ask me let's say if
they're they're dating and they're they
want some advice on whether
they're compatible I say so are you are
you a boy yeah you a girl yeah okay
you're not compatible so she's good go
from there but no it's also through the
action of Christ it's raised to the
dignity of a sacrament so you're also
getting that third party in there you
know bishop machines wonderful 1951 book
three to get married tells the tale very
very well of the the sacramental grace
that you bestow on on your wife and she
to you so you kind of you are the
sacrament together so congratulations
it's it's all I ever say it's a lot of
fun it's a lot of fun I am I am looking
forward to it certainly and you know I
keep saying I've been having a lot of
fun in the run-up to the wedding so I've
been telling sweet little ELISA
things like you know hey I think you're
gonna make a great starter wife or you
know I can't I can't wait for my first
wedding I can't you know I hope maybe
it'll be less stressful on my second one
and she does remind me she says you know
you're Catholic pal which means you are
stuck with me for all of eternity
there's no but there's there's a lot of
confusion about marriage these days I
love that you bring up the suffering
which is I think the most Catholic
answer you could give and very profound
now we're very confused about marriage
there are new definitions of marriage
certainly by the logic of that Oberkfell
decision it seems that there's no reason
to preclude polygamous marriages anymore
the nature of the whole thing keeps
changing even within one man and one
woman the nature of the institution is
quite different now over the last 50 60
hundred years people are getting married
later there are different financial
arrangements feminism has reared its
ugly pink hat clad head you know there
are a lot of things that have affected
marriage is there any hope to bringing a
consensus back to marriage or are we all
going our own directions I think there's
a lot more Hope than there is despair
and the reason I say that is there's a
common myth that's float around I've
actually heard bishops repeat the myth
and it's the 50/50 divorce rate so you
know marriage rates 50 percent it's not
true that comes from a misunderstood gar
bold interpretation of a 1990 Lewis
Harris poll and it failed to distinguish
between people who had been married once
and never divorced and people who had
been multiply divorced in marriage and
and and remarried so imagine you're at a
year out at you're at a dinner party and
there's 12 couples there and one of the
couples is Liz Taylor and one of her
husband's so how do you reckon the
divorce rate at the table right well it
depends there's a researcher named
Shanti Feld on who has a book on this
and she says that for people just
starting have never been married before
the divorce rates under 30 percent now
it depends on on where in the world that
you you know cite that she's mostly
dealing with American demographics but I
think you're right about the obergefell
hodges decision of 2015 that was that
was a big seismic shift change in our
culture and one of the interesting
ironies to me having debated it before
during and after that decision is rather
than a get into a conversation about
homosexual behavior or B be on the
defensive and talk about real marriage
or traditional marriage ask the person
who's advocating for the redefinition of
marriage what his or her definition of
marriage is like finish the sentence
marriages and what you'll find is
invariably their definition of marriage
never mentions sex huh
ours e sounds like a boring marriage
yeah yeah a lot of Scrabble a violent
backgammon apparently so yeah their
definition of marriage tends to be some
combination of well as so it's a warm
emotional lifelong commitment between
two people and you say hold on a second
why - I'm your definition why would you
limit marriage to monogamy what's wrong
with polygamy and this is where it
becomes the thin edge of the wedge so I
always encourage people who'd like to
see marriage defined as it's been
publicly defined for 4,000 years this
this definition by the way predates
Judaism this is not a Bible based only
you know Jesus pointy hat Pope document
kind of definition this belongs to human
nature then marriage is the lifelong
union of one man and one woman
till death open to the
venture Parenthood that's what marriage
is now if you want to have a zebra okay
you can argue for zebras but it's not a
thoroughbred
that's a put it yet different kind not
just in in degree well they they found
to sometimes people will say they'll say
well what about in in the Old Testament
a you know men had multiple wives and
you say okay sure
so I'll even I'll even grant that over
the course of history union of marriage
has been the union of a husband and
wives at least one wife and you know
sometimes multiple wives it had that's
still pretty strict and that still kick
includes the complementarity of the
sexes I love you know in that decision
in the big Supreme Court decision that
changed the definition of marriage
Justice Kennedy wrote he said that the
Constitution offered us a right to
intimacy which I never found that and
then maybe it's it's somewhere in
article five that I should have come out
earlier I wish I'd known that but he I
loved in Scalia's dissent the late great
Justice Scalia he said okay even if you
find a right to intimacy surely marriage
constricts or rather than expands the
opportunities for intimacy ask the
nearest hippie and that seems to be some
of the illogic of their argument yeah
yeah yeah a hundred percent so yeah
that's that's good so I so that that
part is all very confused out of this
confused culture because we can't let
more than eleven minutes go on this show
without discussing Donald Trump but I'd
like your perspective on it as a
Catholic because evangelical so out of
this confused culture we elected Donald
Trump you know and he's done a pretty
good job so far
evangelical Christians fundamentalist
Christians that kind of variety of
American Christianity they're getting a
lot of flack because they've largely
supported Donald Trump and Catholics
like me who have supported Donald Trump
I don't know we get a little less flak
and I wonder if that's because the
Catholic faith is different and makes
different claims than fundamentalist
varieties and evangelical varieties but
why are the evangelicals getting it so
hard and and is it okay for a believing
Christian
who goes to church to support Donald
Trump that is an excellent question I
don't want to give you a glib answer so
this show is all glitz line all clubs
dominate for 14 minutes no I think you I
think it's a very interesting question
for a couple of reasons my answer would
be something like this America in its
founding documents is quasi Protestant
it's secular but there's a kind of a
Christian soul to it you read the works
of the Tocqueville and Chesterton's
ruminations about traveling here in
America the Catholic faith is a kind of
an exotic bird to most American
Protestants they just don't get that
someone can be a citizen of one country
and not have a political leader in Rome
and this is where John F Kennedy made
his I think does that maybe disastrous
is overstating it but his 1960 speech to
the ministers in Houston where he
basically promised to be a bad Catholic
right his faith would not inform his
political decision decisions
well Catholics who are disciples of
Jesus Christ do not believe that God
especially gave the USA the promise of
the Holy Spirit you know that this
country was not formed without original
sin it's not going to be preserved
forever jesus promised the spirit to his
church and so Catholic citizens of all
variety of political systems can coexist
and flourish under communism under
Republic under representative government
under p.m. Canadian or English
jurisprudence so we're not as wedded to
one way of being a citizen in us in the
social political order and I think
[Music]
therefore Catholics are we're not wedded
so much to who's in that office because
we don't put our trust and print in
Princes and and so on I think ultimately
I think yeah I think our our point of
loyalty is higher than the person who
sits in the White House I think you're
exactly right I think that's it there is
among certain varieties of Christianity
in America I think people endowed the
White House in the Oval Office with this
quasi religious
a clerical status which I don't even
know if Catholics afford that status to
the Pope you know I mean it really has
right a special religious honor to it
and Catholics we just say you know yeah
okay this guy's in office he's doing
good things he says some funny things
sometimes and there will be another guy
after him and another guy after him and
eventually it'll all go away because to
quote John Maynard Keynes
which I do infrequently but I like this
one quote in the long run we're all dead
yeah and until we get eternal life
what that's right then another guy will
return yeah but a big bowl and
everything it's funny how worldview
comes through an art sometimes you've
probably seen this in various meme
foreign forms online it's a very
Protestant II kind of a thing all due
respect to my separated brethren out
there listening and watching but it's a
picture of I first saw it with President
Bush and he's at the White House he's
and he's in prayer okay so the Bible is
on the on the Oval Office desk and he's
in prayer and above him there's Jesus
like the the Mormon missionary Jesus
with his hand on Bush's shoulder and
there is Abraham Lincoln and there's
George Washington wait a second that's
the community of the same yeah that's
right yeah what happened they all have
to be President anyway that's exactly
right I think it gets to the point that
everybody's got to serve somebody and I
find when people reject aspects of faith
natural aspects of faith they just get
really superstitious so they say oh how
could you ever pray to the Saints but
then there's this deification of Abraham
Lincoln or George Washington or
something very good message you know
probably act probably they are Saints
but you've got to believe in the Saints
first before I let you go I've got a
couple more minutes i I want to ask you
about a really important question you
smoke the occasional cigar you have the
occasional guy's a scotch I do and by
boat I've been known to do that a bit
myself I notice conservative guys tend
to flock to those two passions and
pursuits and especially the Catholics
especially the why is that what is it
about the conservative character and the
Christian character the catholic
character because a lot of you know
certain Protestant groups they say
no drinking you can't drink you know
there are a little more teetotaling some
of my waspy ancestors were like that the
Catholic side you know they pour a lot
of wine what is it about the
Conservatives and the Catholics that
make us like to have a good time every
now and again excellent question
I heard a ribble joke from a former
Southern Baptist and I'll share it with
you it's it's the observation that
strict Southern Baptists are not
permitted to have sex standing up not
even in marriage do you know why no
might lead to dancing so the Catholic
worldview is very much focused on John
10 verse 10 I came that you would have
life and have it abundantly
the the scene at the wedding at Cana
makes no sense whatsoever if what
they're drinking is grape juice right
because there's there's a implication
there and also one of the Proverbs says
you know wine makes you happy one you
know gladdens the heart I can attest hot
so I can I've experimented yeah so
that's that's to the for the whiskey and
the adult beverages in moderation of
course now for the cigar smoking I
believe there is a almost biblical
precedent for this and it runs like this
under the old dispensation God commanded
the Hebrews to incense the temple as
part of the Jewish liturgy how much more
in the new dispensation the new covenant
should we incense the temple of the body
the are hold the Holy Spirit temple of
the body that is so try frequently said
this the body is a temple and the temple
needs incense
it's my little Cuba thurible you know I
have to I I think it was a good rent
yeah it's gonna be when I retire when
Ben retires me finally and fires me
that's gonna be my new line of that's
gonna be my new line of work
making thurible cigars the GK Chesterton
who I think you've only referenced a
hundred and fifty times in the last six
minutes Chesterton said the Catholic
Church is like a thick steak a glass of
red wine and a good cigar and even in
that first miracle at Cana it's it's
turning the water of ritual into the
wine of celebration and it's and it's
also obviously prefiguring the water and
the blood the the Christ's blood that
flows on the cross
but there there is such a joy that comes
out of that right it's hey guys yeah
this is the good news this isn't the
second hour news right and you're about
to participate in that in that great
mystery that great sacrament of
matrimony and it's called matrimony I
think for a profound reason matrimony
makes mothers monter is Latin for mother
and hence that connection with fertility
and fecundity and Union and the wedding
at Cana miracle is very interesting to
me because he doesn't heal anybody by it
he just does it because it's a
supercharged supernatural injection of
joy into an already happy moment and
it's just one more reason to love being
Catholic that's so true yeah yeah that's
really good and at my wedding I'm
certainly following in the footsteps of
that first miracle I suppose I'm gonna
have to lean in to that free-flowing red
wine and take one for the take one for
the team you know
well Patrick that is this is um there's
no way I'm gonna run for the door sweet
little ELISA might run and leave a sweet
little ELISA shaped hole in the wall but
I'm very excited to get married and I
appreciate it when I get back we'll have
to do a cigar and scotch back on the
west coast your lips to God's ears that
would be great right and keep in touch
if folks want to keep in touch coffin
nation.com
launching a membership site and I
appreciate your time absolutely and
where can people find you on Twitter and
Facebook and all that yep very good it's
well the public page is Patrick often
author and podcaster demigod something
and Patrick underscore coffin at Twitter
and caffeination calms a good spot to to
start well I got a salve ah I've always
loved your programs on the radio on
podcast it's really helped me think
through a faith in Christianity and you
know and issues even even more banal
than all that and you know more more
political and cultural and all that I've
always enjoyed your your programs and
writings so I urge you to read Patrick's
books and check out his shows alright we
got to move on
Thank You Patrick all right thanks a lot
take care we will move on to the mailbag
but I got to say goodbye I'm sorry guys
I got a good mailbag today and we're
gonna have to fly through it because I
got to go catch a flight you know I I'm
hanging out with Allie Stuckey later
today she's coming by and I
wonder how long she's gonna excoriate me
for how Popa SHhhh this show was today
for talking to Patrick off and I'm gonna
get a gonna get a good talking-to from
my Protestant friend if you're on
Facebook or YouTube go to Daley wire if
you're on Daley wire thank you very much
you help us keep the lights on you keep
khofifah in my cup go to Daley wire.com
you get me the and reclaim ensure the
Ben Shapiro show $10 a month 100 hours
for an annual membership none of that
matters because when those NFL players
when they can't kneel when little rocket
man just starts getting a one-way ticket
straight to the moon we blast them off
the face of the earth these leftist
tears are gonna flow and I won't be with
you for you know my honeymoon I'm not
gonna be around I am obviously bringing
this to the beach with me not to save me
from the ocean but to save me from all
the leftist tears you should too it's
the only fda-approved device go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back with the
mailbag
not a lot of time left but we're gonna
fly through we're gonna do as much as we
can from mark dear Michael J Knowles or
current resident I've been Shapiro broom
closet congratulations on your upcoming
nuptials my brother is getting married
this Saturday and I'm delivering the
best man speech if you have a younger
brother if you had one is there anything
that you would want him to say is your
best man and is there anything you would
not want him to say all the best Mark
Levin is that the real Mark Levin now I
don't know if you're getting me okay
that's a Mark Levin yes I have strong
opinions about this I have very strong
opinions about speeches at weddings
because they're all terrible and there
are too many of them
and they're terrible statistically 100%
of the time so yes here's the main thing
I've helped people write speeches for
weddings before and here's what I do
they hand me a little piece of paper
like this and I read through their
speech and I cross out every instance of
the first person singular pronoun
because this is what it always goes they
the best man now sometimes maid of honor
gives a speech because you know the
glory of Europe is extinguished forever
in the age of chivalry is dead and so
the best man whoa let's say he gets out
there and I'll say you know I couldn't
be happier for Johnny
I remember when Johnny and I were doing
something that I like to do with me and
then he and I did this and it was really
funny for me and then then frequent so
okay the first bit is don't talk about
yourself if you're giving the speech
talk about the couple talk about the
bride in the groom the next one is and
this should be a basic one but this
happens all the time if you're given the
speech about the bride or the groom do
not reference other people with whom
they have had sex I know that seem that
you would think that would be basic
etiquette I have been to many weddings
many weddings where the the best man or
the maid of honor will talk about like
past boyfriends and oh you should have
seen that guy she was bringing home you
know dad I don't want to think about
that on the wedding day what's the
matter with you so get that one out of
there remember it's not about you don't
talk about
room having sex with other people and
keep it short keep it really short this
is not this is supposed to be a toast
and okay and then I've been to somewhere
the bride and the groom speak don't do
that
don't your look it's a people want to
see you as like a little figure on a
cake they want you to be beautiful and
nice you don't need to talk the minute
you open your mouth you're gonna shatter
that fantasy this is a day of people
doing nice things for you you don't need
to speak and then all of this I mean all
these speeches now they're this father
and they're that father traditionally
speaking it's the father of the bride
and the best man boom that's it
one and done get out of here now like
you know everybody has to go it's like
the roasts it's like a Dean Martin roast
or something
none of that keep it short keep it sweet
and you know focus on the stuff that
matters you're there with your friends
you're celebrating that you've had a
sacrament together do that don't don't
put on a don't put on a variety act up
there okay next question from Marcus
dear Michelangelo detrolio Michelangelo
de troll edema D Mikado I've noticed
that you don't end your shows with stuff
I like is this because in Catholicism if
you like something that it's probably a
sin it's good observation in all
seriousness stuff I like can help your
audience get to know you for example do
you prefer fiction to nonfiction do you
enjoy any music from the 1900s that
isn't in a musical or movie score will
look in a uShip Bureau do you enjoy
movies with leftist messages despite
their messaging yeah I don't really do
stuff I like although I got it I have to
push back a little on the Catholic thing
because we do go into suffering and we
do you know Mia culpa mea culpa but I
believe it was Puritanism which was
defined as the heart-stopping fear that
somewhere someone is having a good time
you know the Catholic Church they pour
out the wine pretty freely at least
there's something there okay what did
you ask so do I enjoy do I prefer
fiction to nonfiction no I prefer
nonfiction I almost exclusively read
nonfiction
even though which is tough cuz one of my
very good friends is a famed novelist
so I really like Drew's books Drew's
books are really good but I just don't
read fiction that much and I should
because fiction is better than
nonfiction and it tells you more about
the human condition I just don't get
around to doing it too much because I'm
I'm too busy reading all these fun books
for people
I talked to on the show do you enjoy any
music from the 1900s 20th century that
isn't in a musical or movie score oh
yeah totally huh
I like a lot of popular music in small
doses I did most of the time I usually
just listen to classical or occasionally
jazz like I never listened to the rock
station in the car or anything like that
I don't run playlists usually books are
classical but yeah if I'm hanging out or
about to go out or you know having a
little after-dinner drink or something
uh yeah I like I like music even up to
like the 1980s it's pretty modern ma'am
that's that's like the most modern
conservative guys get how many more
questions did you I write well I lost my
place so no one's that here from Corey
dear Michael I've found as I've taken
more responsibility in my life and dug
more into what it means to be
conservative and conservative values I
found myself growing stronger in my
Christian faith as I saw a clear
correlation why is it that some
conservatives try to separate themselves
from the Christian faith that is part of
the pillar of conservatism thanks Cory
it's because they don't recognize it
it's because they don't we can extend
this a little bit to - to Jews
non-religious Jews they don't they don't
see how all of these thoughts come out
of they come back as early as Genesis
right if they just don't recognize it I
think I I don't think that they are
actively disagreeing with true religion
and the religious basis of these thought
I just think they haven't thought
through it really I it it has frequently
been said I forget whose quote this is
maybe it's Chesterton all the quotes are
Chesterton is that no one has ever tried
the Christian faith and found it lacking
or you know a sale to the Christian
faith successfully they just a sale a
caricature they try the Christian faith
day and they find it hard and they don't
want to keep doing it or something you
know that is I think the real issue so
if people say I want low taxes but I
don't care about all that abortion stuff
I heard this Ann Coulter once said to me
I was with a group of college students
and she said when you have two
candidates even if you personally don't
care about abortion when you have two
candidates who promise to lower your
taxes one is pro-life one supports
abortion vote for the candidate who is
pro-life he will lower your taxes more
and what she's saying is the candidate
who the the lower taxes that comes from
a defense of liberty and appreciation of
Liberty and life and one's role in the
world and that comes from natural rights
which come from natural law which comes
from the natural law giver which comes
from the Christian tradition which comes
from which then leads on to bioethical
thought the human dignity how we ought
to protect life from the very beginning
life either has value or it doesn't life
is either sacred or it's not sacred
innocent life and so there's a coherence
to the that one guy's thought the pro
life cut your taxes guy that there isn't
for the pro-choice cut your taxes guy
excuse me so those people are plenty of
conservatives who say oh I'm an atheist
or I don't think about religion or I'm
spiritual but not religious and I'm glad
great be a conservative that's fabulous
I'm thrilled to have you but when you
start thinking a little bit about it I
think that that atheism is gonna wear
away do we have time for one or two more
all right we got time for one more one
that's it just one more from Jonathan
that's too bad I had really good
questions in here today well maybe I'll
they'll do like a Facebook live from the
beach or something from Jonathan hello I
am going to be a junior in college this
coming academic year but I'm unsure
about keeping my major in business
administration and I'm unsure of what I
want to do when I graduate college
I have many paths to choose but I know
that only one of them can be chosen are
there any tips you have for matters like
this don't become an actor that's my
main advice that's my professional
advice to everybody what should I do
don't be an actor that's my main advice
okay you're in an interesting position
so I don't you know regardless of what
the major is I don't know that your
major is going to determine what you do
I'll just use my own life as an example
I studied history and Italian literature
I've trained at very serious acting
conservatories for a long time I moved
to New York I worked in politics and in
theater theater in New York film
television moved to LA was still working
in both of those things then I ended up
not writing a book now I have a show now
your your
rear can take pretty weird paths does
any of that have to do with my Italian
literature degree or my history degree
or my CC as I wrote in college I don't
know maybe maybe not you you should not
go into a lot of debt to just just cuz
you shouldn't go to law school just cuz
you know cuz that's the next thing to do
you should go to law school because you
want to be a lawyer you should go to
medical school because you want to be a
doctor but if you can't plan these
things out perfectly so I don't I
wouldn't worry that you have to plan
everything out when you're a junior just
work God God can't drive a parked car
so just work be doing don't be thinking
about what you're gonna do be doing it
I've been doing show business stuff and
working in politics for as long as I can
remember certainly since I was 18 and
just doing it do it through college just
keep doing and the more you do you're
gonna be able to figure out maybe I'm
good at this I'm better at this I should
try to do this a little bit more okay
maybe I'll take this class then because
of that but you're gonna figure it out
by doing you're not gonna figure it out
by philosophizing and thinking and
abstracting everything you're a
conservative don't live in abstraction
don't live in theory live in practice
okay that's our show I got to go catch a
flight well I got to hang out with Allie
Stuckey and get yelled at first but then
I got to catch a flight so I will see
you guys I'll be broadcasting all next
week from New York tune in for that have
a good Memorial Day weekend don't do
anything that I wouldn't do but it'll be
my bachelor party so that will give you
I'll give you a pretty wide breath in
the meantime I'm Michael nose this is
the Michael Noel's show I'll see you
next week
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018